welcome back to a segment that could
save a life yours or someone you love
February is American Heart month and
this morning what we're going to do is
learn exactly what you need to do if it
looks like someone in your vicinity
isn't breathing or their heart has
stopped and we called in the experts to
help us we've got Dr John lapuke cbs's
chief medical correspondent you know him
well and we brought in another expert Dr
Deepak prey Dawn is a critical care
specialist at NYU NYU langone and this
we have a name for our dummy helper here
no I'm aimless nameless show remains
nameless for now uh let's begin with
with the key question which is how do
you know that somebody's actually in
Cardiac Arrest it's a great question
because people are afraid Somebody went
down how do I know they didn't just
faint so Dr pradan is going to take us
through the beginning of that so start
with the basics see if they're
responsive get down and say Sir Sir can
you hear me sir and then shake their
their shoulders
gently it's no response and then go
ahead shot one more time sir can you
respond sir can you respond
patient is unresponsive Tony call 9-1-1
we need emergency help now Dr lepuc grab
the AED bring it back right away
next is the AED right and we're going to
pretend that it's not here because it's
generally not right by the way great
great instincts in sending me to dial a
phone I can do that part yeah great so
next I just want to see if they have a
pulse so I'm going to put my two fingers
into the into their neck and feel for a
pulse I'm also looking at their chest to
see if it's rising and falling with
breathing I do this for about five to
ten seconds
no the patient is unresponsive there is
no pulse there's no evidence of
breathing so this is all consistent with
Cardiac Arrest okay so now I'm going to
start hands-only CPR so bystander CPR so
you're going to take your the heel of
your of your one hand put it right in
the center of the chest right between
the nipples you know take your other
hand put it right over top rock yourself
forward so that your shoulders are over
top of your hands and then you are going
to start lock your elbows and then start
pumping hard and fast 100 to 120 times
per minute wow
wow and the and that's serious pressure
yeah and it's to the tune of staying
alive staying alive all right okay all
right now this is happening all right
now let's say the AED has now arrived
okay we're gonna put it over here and uh
Tony you have never used an A.D no never
had any instruction right never I am
going to give you one piece of advice
after you open it okay
all you have to do is hit the on off
button and it will talk you through the
whole thing okay
I'm hitting it go for it
yes the pads need to be directly on the
skin
spare open great plastic case and peel
off white adhesive pads
go ahead okay
look carefully at the pictures on the
white adhesive pads feel one white pad
from the gray case now the audience may
not be able to see this
uh okay excuse me doctor yep
peel the second Pad Place pad exactly as
shown
excellent okay
okay stay clear of patience everything's
awesome analyzing heart rhythm now
people are worried they're gonna what if
you shock somebody who doesn't need to
be shocked right it's programmed only to
give a shot if it's needed which is what
is happening now it is not goodbye stay
clear of patients press the flashing
orange button now
shot delivered right resume CPR until
the heart is going to restart the ad
will be analyze in two minutes
he's getting tired
you're going to now do CPR
it's going to tell you how to do
something you're going to do what I'm
doing yeah what it's saying you do so
we're going to switch in three on top
firmly perfect
now the reason
excellent because people get go too fast
sometimes they get excited now what's so
important here is this would not have
given a shock if the person didn't need
it and once somebody goes down for every
minute of delay getting a post back
survival goes down seven to ten percent
so the CPR will buy you time right but
it you're ultimately going to be saved
by the shock being delivered if the
person has a shockable rhythm so that's
CPR first AED this is exactly the kind
of device that saved the life of Demar
Hamlin so let's turn this off
Tony you have just zero instruction
beforehand right no zero and you have
potentially saved a life so now now
potentially Dr lepuc thank you very much
uh Dr perdon you're very good at this uh
I want you around if this is ever me
okay but we need to make the point that
people need to know where the AED
machine is in their place and this is
very doable this is very doable people
should feel comfortable with this if you
see it uh know where it is know how to
use it it'll teach you how to use it
Tony there's ten thousand cardiac
arrests in the workplace every year and
only about 50 percent of Americans know
where their AED is located at work and
so we can do better we should yeah
exactly and the last point I want to
make is for people watching this if
you're in an office go to your office
manager and say Hey where's the IED
where's the course and if you're home
what a great thing to have a party or a
get together at your home with friends
family have a CPR AED course and that
includes one for infants and children
and a first aid course for infants and
children wine is heart healthy as well
you can bring that to the party thank
you both very much